we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our next caller from the 401
7 area code call it from 401 7 tell us
who you are and what's on your mind
today
hey David I'm Erin Talley I'm from Jo Jo
Missouri great what's up no I was just I
just wanted to ask you on your opinion
of Justice Democrats a pact was started
by jiang cuter and kyle kolinsky to run
primary campaigns against the more
corporate Democrat mmm yeah so I don't
know what or who they are supporting
specifically I know conceptually that
that's the idea as you stated it I am
sometimes in favor of primary Democrats
and other times depending on the
situation I'm not so like for example
people have called in about West
Virginia and Joe Manchin like joe
Manchin is probably the most right-wing
Democratic senator right now in the
Senate and the idea of primary in here
and my view is hey there are their House
seats from Virginia from West Virginia
held by Republicans what about taking
the money that you would use to primary
joe Manchin and then maybe end up losing
the general election to instead try to
win back some of those Republican House
seats so in terms of the strata comment
on is the strategy of primary endemic
rats and I am open to that idea I'm not
always in favor of it it sort of depends
on the circumstances it depends on the
state it depends on what impact the
primary challenge might have on the
eventual general election okay now yeah
I tend to agree with that I think the
actually the better way to go be
determine more states like in say
Connecticut and Massachusetts that are
safer democratic states that still have
the more establishment types of
politicians like Ed Markey or former
Connecticut Senator Joe Lieberman for
example yeah although I think Markey and
Lieberman are different I actually think
Mark II is not mark Markey is closer I
think to what we want then Lieberman was
for sure but I understand the idea and
yet you don't want to end
turning a seat over to Republicans due
to a primary challenge and I understand
the ideology of it but I also think that
we need to be aware of the pragmatics of
it especially when we're trying to take
back the House and Senate in 2018 all
right Aaron very much appreciate the
call thank you so much hope to hear from
you again let's take a break we will
take calls again and we will answer some
audience questions after the break